and now we're going to go back to the
grog and tuck in Australian take it away
Rachel and Ryan thanks Bill
excuse me for not going in Billy but
that's what we make our tea in down here
American films have introduced American
culture to the rest of the world we're
in Australia have attempted to follow
that lead in presenting our stories with
our people one of the hurdles we had to
face in the early 70s was not being
understood by you people in America you
might not be aware of it but in the
first Mad Max for example Mel Gibson was
reavoice that of course isn't the case
today
it's a pity it isn't fun because no one
can understand a word you're saying
our second award if the sound effects
editing which presents less problems for
us as these sounds are universal the
nominates the best achievement in sound
effects editing our Black Rain Milton C
borrow and William L manger
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade ben
burtt and richard him
lethal weapon to Robert Henderson and
Alain Robert Murray and the Oscar for
best achievement in sound effects
editing goes to Ben bird and Richard
hamster Indiana Jones and
well we have a lot of people to thank we
want to thank the members of the Academy
we want to thank our family at Skywalker
Sound North all the people that have
given us such support and putting these
films together and especially George
Lucas and Steven Spielberg who have
inspired us and taken us on so many
adventures that we could enjoy together
thank you very much I would like to
thank Ken Fisher Terry Acton sandy
Novello and David stone for their
seamless sound effects and Foley editing
I would also like to thank those people
who have made my career a happy a
successful one especially those in San
Francisco and in particular my partner
allows free films for his encouragement
of support Ben Burtt thank you Ben and
thank you for all the 62nd annual
Academy
we'll be back with Gregory
you